whereas to construct a perpendicular
bisector of the line segment a b
so the fact is perpendicular means that
this line will make a 90 degree angle
where it intersects with a b and it's
going to bisect it so it's going to go
halfway in between and i have at my
disposal some tools i can put out i can
draw things with a compass and i can add
a straight edge so let's try this out so
let me add a compass and so this is kind
of a virtual compass so in a real
compass it's one of those little metal
things where you can pivot it on one
point and you can draw a circle of any
radius and so here i'm going to draw i'm
going to center it at a
i'm going to center it at a and i'm
going to make the radius equal to the
length of a b
now i'm going to add another circle
with my compass
and now i'm going to center it at b
and make the radius equal to
equal to a b
and now this gives me two points that i
can actually use to draw my
perpendicular bisector if i connected
this point and this point it is going to
bisect a b and it's also going to be
perpendicular so let's add a straight
edge here so this is to draw a line so
i'm going to draw a line between that
point
and
that point right over there let me
scroll down so you can look at a little
bit clearer so there you go that's my
construction i've made a perpendicular
bisector for segment a b
check my answer we got it right